S&P 500 UP TWO.
THE NASDAQ GAINED THE TEN.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER, VIRGINIA'S
EMBATTLED DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
AND LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ARE
STILL REFUSING TO LEAVE OFFICE
IN THE MISTS OF THEIR TWIN
SCANDALS.
AN UPDATE FROM RICHMOND.
>> I BELIEVE WE NEED TO GIVE THE
GOVERNOR A SECOND CHANCE.
>> FOR GENERIC GOVERNOR RALPH
NORTH RALPH NORTHAM RATE
EXCEEDING ENCOURAGEMENT FROM A
GROUP OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN CLERGY
AND LOCAL LEADERS WHO SAYS THAT
HE'S IN A DIFFERENT MAN FROM 30Y
HE'S IN A DIFFERENT MAN FROM 30A
HE'S IN A DIFFERENT MAN FROM 30S
AGO WHEN HE WORE A BLACK FACE.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH CBS, THE
GOVERNOR SAID HE'S NOT GOING
ANYWHERE AND WANTS TO USE THIS
CONTROVERSY TO HELP HIM ADDRESS
RACIAL INEQUALITY IN HIS STATE.
>> RIGHT NOW, VIRGINIA NEED
SOMEONE WHO CAN HEAL.
THERE IS NO BETTER TO DO THAT
THAN A DOCTOR.
I WILL FOCUS ON RACE AND EQUITY.
THAT SOMETHING FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS IS GOING TO BE MY
COMMITMENT TO VIRGINIA AND I
REALLY THINK WE CAN MAKE AN
IMPACT.
>> NORTHAM DREW FRESH CRITICISM
FOR THE WAY HE DESCRIBED THE
FIRST AFRICANS BROUGHT TO
VIRGINIA BY SLAVE TRADERS.
>> JUST 90 MILES HERE IN 1619,
THE FIRST INDENTURED SERVANTS
FROM AFRICA LANDED ON OUR SHORES
ON WHAT WE CALL FORT MONROE --
>> ALSO KNOWN AS SLAVERY.
>> YES.
>> JUSTIN FAIRFAX ALSO REFUSING
TO STEP DOWN AFTER BEING ACCUSED
BY TWO WOMEN OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
>> I DO WANT TO REITERATE THAT
JUSTIN FAIRFAX SHOULD RESIGN.
>> HE'S HOLDING OFF ON
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS TO
REMOVE FAIRFAX FROM OFFICE WHILE
LAWMAKERS EXPLORE OTHER OPTIONS
FOR INVESTIGATING THE CLAIMS
AGAINST HIM.
BOTH OF FAIRFAX'S ACCUSERS
WILLING TO TESTIFY AND
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS, BUT AT THE
CAPITOL NOT EVERYONE IS
CONVINCED THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY
WOULD BE ABLE TO CONDUCT A
MEANINGFUL INVESTIGATION.
>> THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY DOES NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SUBPOENA
WITNESSES.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO PRESENT THEIR
INDIVIDUAL CASES BEFORE A BODY
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO    TO D
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO    TO O
SOMETHING WITH IT.
>> FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT
FOUR STAFFERS OF LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AIR JUSTIN FAIRFAX HAVE
RESIGNED SINCE FRIDAY WHEN A
SECOND WOMAN CAME FORWARD WITH
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATIONS.
FAIRFAX HAS ALSO BEEN PLACED ON
LEAVE BY THE LAW FIRM WHERE HE